[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein israel
ich habe heute morgen eine umfrage
gemacht und gefragt ist es schon zu spät
für zwetschgenkuchen oder es ist noch
okay und ich glaube 85 prozent oder 90
waren es die gesagt haben ja noch zeit
spucken also geht es jetzt in choren
zwetschgendatschi einmal ganz
traditionell mit hefeteig vom blech
einmal eine schnelle variante mit quark
öl teig und am ende machen wir eine
verkostung und ihr könnt ja mal schon
mal in die kommentare schreiben
mögt ihr zwetschgenkuchen mögt ihr ihn
mit hefeteig oder quark öl teig oder
rührteig und mit streusel oder ohne
streusel weil ich glaube dass ist so die
grundsatzdiskussion immer was sagt er
mit streusel marx allee mit ok ich
glaube wir machen später vielleicht halb
halb und dann gucken wir mal
aber ich bin auch eher so der fan mit
streuseln also jetzt erstmal hier zum
hefeteig für ein ganzes blech ich nehme
dafür 21 gramm hefe das ist ein halber
würfel einen esslöffel wasser 40 gramm
zucker 350 gramm mehl da können der
dinkel oder weizen nehmen etwa 150 bis
180 gramm milch etwas salz und 40 gramm
weicher butter was sich später auch
machen werde ist ich mache noch einen
runden kuchen also falls ihr mal weniger
zweit- und könnt ihr das ganze natürlich
auch in rund machen müsst nicht direkt
ein ganzes blech packen und ich werde
dann einfach auch die vegane version
machen denn gerade so ein hefeteig kann
man echt super vegan zu bereiten
streusel auch und dann schreibe ich euch
da die vegane version einfach auch mit
auf dem blog und dann habt ihr das auch
und in meiner app könnt ihr auch
wirklich alle zutaten hoch und runter
rechnen lassen also auch wenn ich ein
blech angeht könnt ihr draußen runden
kuchen backen oder eben auch andersrum
jetzt hier am besten zuerst die hefe mit
wasser und zucker vermischen
[Musik]
die milch mache ich jetzt gerade noch
kurz war nur dass die so ein bisschen
lauwarm ist das besser für den hefeteig
dass die eben nicht aus dem kühlschrank
kommt das reicht schon
und jetzt gebt ihr einfach alle zutaten
hier rein direkt das ganze mehl salz und
milch bei der milch bin ich immer erst
mal ein bisschen vorsichtig gebe ein
bisschen weniger dazu und butter und
soll es einfach immer ganz zum schluss
damit die nicht direkt mit der hefe in
verbindung kommt und jetzt könnt ihr den
teig einfach zu einem richtig schönen
geschmeidigen teig kneten
[Musik]
so sieht der teig perfekt aus und lässt
sich gut lösen ist schön weich aber auch
nicht zu weich hat ich habe ein bisschen
milch tatsächlich noch übrig das hätte
ich meine hände so ein bisschen die
tanzform das ganze selbst so einer
schönen kugel jetzt können daher auch
die schüssel so ein bisschen fetzen die
kugel rein legen die oberfläche fetten
damit sie nicht austrocknet und dann den
teig abgedeckt für etwa eine stunde auf
gehen lassen bis sich verdoppelt hat
falls ihr die geher stufe am backofen
habt also einen dampf backofen könnt ihr
den auch dort bei 34 grad mit dampf
aufgehen lassen
da halbiert sich die aufgezeigt und der
teig wird einfach schön luftig und
trocknet eben an der oberfläche nicht
aus das mache ich eben mal schnell
[Musik]
also den runden kuren mache ich jetzt
vegan da habe ich jetzt hier schon hier
für zucker und wasser vermischt
da gebe ich die zutaten auch direkt in
die schüssel und statt butter nämlich
vegane butter und statt normaler mensch
nehme ich einfach hafer milch oder eben
eine andere pflanze und das war's dann
im prinzip schon
[Musik]
so ein süßer kleiner teil das bak trance
break das ist auch egal dass nämlich nur
kokosfett und rapsöl und den lasse ich
jetzt auch schön aufgehen und kann ihnen
dazwischen zeit für den blechkuchen
einfach schon mal die streusel zu
bereiten
denn wir machen ja halb halb mit
streifen und oder streusel für die
streusel nämlich 90 gramm butter und 90
gramm zucker einen teelöffel salz 180
gramm
da könnt ihr auch weizen oder dinkel
nehmen und zum verfeinern einen
teelöffel zimt und auch hier bei der
veganen version einfach veganer butter
verwenden und dann habt ihr schon vegane
crumble ich gebe jetzt hier alle zutaten
in die küchenmaschine ihr könnt aber
auch alles mit einem tacker so ein
bisschen zu hacken oder kurz die finger
benutzen geht beides wunderbar salz ist
übrigens immer super wichtig und wenn
ihr vanille streusel machen wollt
einfach an den extrakt wenn ihr tonga
streusel machen wollt einfach tonkabohne
mit rein also die könnt ihr auch echt
super verfeinern und jetzt kurz
vermischen
[Musik]
aber die mutter wohl noch zu kalt die
darf ruhig ein bisschen weich sein
vielleicht einfach länger hören dann
macht es auch nicht so eine sauerei
[Musik]
so sehen die streusel es perfekt aus
also so schöne grobe streusel falls sie
zu fangen sind ich hatte eben auch das
problem war einfach weil die butter noch
zu kalt war dann gibt der den stress und
einfach so ein bisschen hand wärme so
ein bisschen zusammendrücken und dann
entstehen so die kann ich jetzt kurz
kalt stellen bis dahin kuchen so weit
ist und kann in der zwischenzeit wenn
ihr nämlich die cvag öl version macht
dann macht die sich scheiße auch
zuallererst weil die eben schneller
fertig sind dann könnt ihr den quark öl
teig direkt danach machen und das mache
ich jetzt denn meine zwetschgen sind
schon entspannt und teil wird für den
kraken teig verwende ich 300 gramm quark
dessen magerquark zwei eier etwa 100
gramm milch 80 sonnenblumenöl oder
rapsöl etwas vanille extrakt 400 gramm
mehl und päckchen backpulver 100 gramm
zucker und etwas salz was ist ein
charakter schätze ist dass er wirklich
super einfach ist man hat keine
aufgezeigt und ich finde den einfach
lecker und locker also immer wenn ich
mal lust auf einen schnellen kuchen habe
oder allgemein auf kuchen ist krank und
eigentlich schon so die beste variante
muss ich sagen obwohl ich einen sechser
großer hefeteig fällen muss das recht zu
geben
und gerade weil so obstkuchen ist schon
quark öl teig so der favorit also ja und
ich hab halt auch mal alle zutaten da
also eier öl und quark die trocken und
sowieso
von daher kann ich den halt auch immer
zu bereiten und ich gehe jetzt hier ihr
seht schon alles in eine schüssel
das ist so ein all-in teig das heißt
alles rein und dann auf einmal verrühren
dann das mehl da könnte jetzt auch
dinkel oder weizen nehmen
backpulver zucker und salz erst mal
anders kommt das war salz und zucker
oder sonst ein bisschen herzhaft wenn
ihr wollt könnt ihr hier noch zitronen
abrieb eingeben oder zimt oder
tonkabohne also auch wieder verfeinern
wie ihr möchtet oder in choco version
dann einfach mit dem kakaopulver jetzt
kurz verrühren in der hoffnung dass
nichts
[Musik]
warum bisschen kleines bisschen
zack schon fertig nicht mal eine minute
verrührt also wirklich nur so weit
führen dass sich alles gut verbunden hat
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier meinen back rahmen
den kann ich jetzt direkt auf blech
größe ausziehen habe hier das lochblech
darunter und eine dauer back folie dann
kommt der teig direkt rein
kurz verstreichen
den ofen habe ich jetzt auch schon
vorgeheizt das ist jetzt natürlich auch
wichtig gerade bei dem kuchen manche 10
mit backpulver arbeit dass da eben jetzt
nicht rum steht sondern direkt in den
warmen ofen kommt jetzt habe ich hier
mein herz wetschen die sind wie gesagt
bereits entstand und halbiert und je
nach größe können diese halbieren oder
vierteln und jetzt einfach schön im
blech verteilen und dann nimmt man halt
auch zwetschgen und keine pflaumen weil
die einfach back stabiler sind und
pflaumen zu westrich sind und die würden
den kuchen halt total verbessern
obwohl ich muss ich sagen pflaumen so
optisch schöner fand aber zum packen
sind hier halt besser
[Musik]
das sieht schon sehr gut aus und wie
gesagt mach ich jetzt die hälfte mit
streuseln und die hälfte ohne streusel
und dann gucken wir mal was besser
ankommt und auf die hilfe der oder
streusel streue ich jetzt einfach noch
mandelblättchen so irgendwas knackig ist
finde ich muss schon dazu entweder
streusel oder eben mandeln dass man so
ein bisschen einfach konsistenzen drin
hat luftiger teig fruchtige zwetschken
und dann so ein knapp und der kuchen
kann jetzt direkt in den backofen also
quark öl teig ist wirklich der kuchen
innerhalb von 20 minuten fertig und dann
im backofen
[Musik]
während der quark öl kuchen fast schon
fertig ist kann ich jetzt hier mit dem
hefeteig weitermachen also schon so eine
sache muss immer echt sagen aber am ende
finde ich zählt dann doch der geschmack
deswegen werden wir gucken aus unserer
besten gefällt also auch den hefeteig
werde ich jetzt hier direkt auf dem
blech geben hier einfach mit den händen
so ein bisschen öffnen falls es kleben
sollte entweder die hände fetten oder
ein bisschen mehr benutzen
schön sind jetzt hier auch wieder die
zwetschgen darüber verteilen
[Musik]
den lasse ich jetzt wieder abgedeckt
eine halbe stunde hohen wert aber schon
mal die hälfte mit den mandeln bestreuen
denn auch jemand nur wieder halb
streusel halb mandeln die streusel gebe
ich aber dann erst nach dem aufgehen
dazu denn ich werde noch mal im ofen
aufgehen lassen
wer kennt es nicht dass die streusel
warm werden also eine halbe stunde kurz
warten und danach direkt im heißen ofen
backen
[Musik]
jetzt da wir in kurven machen
also wir haben hier kuchen nummer eins
zwetschgenkuchen vom blech mit hefeteig
nummer zwei zwetschgenkuchen mit quark
öl teig nummer 3 20 uhr mit quark öl
teig unglück
der unterschied ist hier probieren wir
hefekuchen und quark öl kuchen ohne
streusel und hier problemen wir quark öl
und hefe mit streuseln aber der plan der
swk was macht eigentlich nix also das
ist denke ich dass das mal ein bisschen
über sich gerne bruder ja und halt kein
okay und eigentlich geht hier vielmehr
reihenfolge oder
es war das aha wir haben also genug um
es auf den boden zu legen
da kommt der veganer ganz so aha da
kommt jetzt noch eine einfache haha wie
gut dass noch eine gabel haben vor sich
auf den boden
hier stehe also eigentlich geht es eher
stimmt deiner stadt ich habe dich hier
zu leben so köhl teig und hefeteig
vergleich und noch mitstreiter
vergleichen
nein es ist so langsam so langsam weiß
dass man probiere ich muss den hut taco
mir ja jeder äußert seine partei dann ja
gut ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir müssen alles super alles vergleich
also ich bin auch so dass alle
unterschiedlich aussehen aber das
alleine ist marokkanische das andere
der feind steuern also falsch gedacht
zu meiner verteidigung warum es nur
eingegangen gibt ich wollte noch den
rührkuchen vegan machen aber ganz setzt
den rahmen des videos gesprengt hat
schon vier gebacken was ist dein favorit
benny alter hefekuchen mit streusel aber
jetzt auch generell bestehe mit
streuseln oder ohne schon mich schon mit
einsteigen favorit kenne ich und meine
ich auch mein favorit was ist dein
verhandler denkst du direkt wir denken
gleich wie normal der sträußen typs co
also quark öl ohne streusel okay ich bin
auch mit streuseln holt man das nur weil
ich bin auch stolz ein typ ich auch noch
durch einen neuen link gebrochen
streusel es so war
hier war das sicher auch gewackelt die
stadt gleiche nur ich halt klar wenn man
in der form war und mit der hulk hogan
artiger und so wieder hat ein bisschen
habe ich ein flacher
das wird ja definitiv also zwetschge
hinterher
wir lieben streuselkuchen wird einfach
jeden einzelnen nacheinander und wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal in
der app könnt ihr übrigens die rezepte
hoch und runter rechnen verdoppeln
verdreifachen einfrieren der körper holt
dafür waren und einfach essen und wir
werden ihnen noch einfrieren dann haben
wir noch ganz lange was davon
[Musik]
und wir werden ihnen noch einfrieren
dann haben wir noch ganz lange etwas
davon jetzt bleibt also du nimmst sehr
komplett ich nehme den mit das ist halt
vielleicht kann man sofort den special
effekt machen alle unten verschenke
ninja und widrigkeiten sind unseren
trader nicht gibt es eine kurve würde
ich muss weitere nämlich dass im
kofferraum
das macht dort 123
ich komm nicht meine meine songs bleiben
wir uns mal wieder hoch aber ich komme
ich mal okay da spielt ab jetzt okay